I'm excited to get into those comments
and answer your questions huge thanks to
Google maps for sponsoring a portion of
this video
why can't you swallow while your mouth
is open
probably has something to do with your
soft palate or your tongue or a negative
pressure that needs to be created I
don't know I'm gonna guess it's
something with a muscle or epiglottis
being closed I don't know the answer is
I don't know don't be afraid to say I
don't know is there a specific rule
preventing a doctor from donating their
own organs or bone marrow to a patient I
don't think that there's any rule in
place for that I wouldn't even see what
would be wrong with that why do I sneeze
more when I have a cold well that has
something to do with the irritation of
the Airways uh remember you have little
hair follicles that actually try and
prevent and catch certain allergens
viral particles mucus when they get
irritated it triggers the sneeze reflex
and encourages you to projectile sneeze
all those things out it's actually a
protective mechanism Max from YouTube uh
is there a health benefit to eating a
piece of meat that's cooked rare versus
well done in healthcare everything has
risk verse reward when you're cooking
something rare you're getting less
harmful compounds created by the flame
interacting with the food so you're
getting less pahs less hcas but then
when it's rare you're also potentially
exposing yourself to some extra
bacterias ideally it's better to find a
middle ground where you're cooking the
meat to the recommended temperature to
kill the possible bacteria that's there
but not overcook it to the point where
you're creating harmful compounds if you
get a testicle transplant I think it's
testicular transplant and got someone
pregnant who would be the biological
father wait do they do testicular trans
this is see you learned something new
every day let's see testicular
transplant oh my God look at this New
York Times surgeons transplant a
testicle from one brother to his twin oh
my God I don't know if that's if your
only testicles are ones that have been
donated to you they're probably
genetically the other persons
I don't know at the drugstore they offer
Advil and then Advil Extra Strength why
would I not want to use a stronger
option well Extra Strength usually just
means that the dosage per pill is higher
you could technically just take more
pills of the regular strength one and
it'll be the same as Extra Strength when
you take more of a dose of a medicine
you actually increase the rate of side
effects and there is a tapering off
effect where you're not going to get
more benefit when you take more dose but
you will have more rates of side effects
so you kind of have to balance that bro
WTF is raw milk isn't all milk raw it
starts off as raw but the milk you get
at like the supermarket is usually
pasteurized milk so it's like heat
treated and the bacteria is killed
that's why in most cases when yogurt is
pasteurized a lot of the bacteria gets
killed they add probiotics to the yogurt
can STIs survive in toilet water would
toilet water splashing up into my
generals infect me you know what's
interesting I just had a patient that
brought this up to me uh this past week
for some reason Young Folks when they
feel embarrassed coming to see a doctor
and talk about their sexual experiences
they say that they believe this happened
as a result of toilet water splashing up
into their genitals look technically you
could probably make an argument that
this could happen the chance of this
happening versus it being from an STI
like transmitted through sex is almost
nil so I would say it's probably
sexually transmitted and at the same
time you shouldn't be embarrassed the
fact that you are sexually active and
you shouldn't be embarrassed to speak to
your doctor about it because we're not
there to judge you we're there to help
you and we can only help you to the best
of our abilities when you're being
honest and truthful what are your
thoughts about nasal irrigation when you
have a cold does it help I love nasal
irrigation with saline sprays that's
like my go-to recommendation for my
patients the nasal saline will clean out
mucus they'll get rid of allergens clear
out viral particles all in all a
positive thing when you have a cold it's
the same way that we recommend salt
water gargles but this is even better
because it's going directly into your
nasal passageways so I'm a fan back to
the questions in just a second but first
I want to thank Google Maps for
sponsoring this part of the video if you
didn't know they provide maps in 99 of
the world's countries and territories
which is why I've been using Google Maps
for years when traveling but there's
actually a ton of uses for Google Maps
when I'm at home especially lists
whenever friends visit me in New York
City they always need recommendations of
where to eat I'm actually the best at
this because I love to eat out using the
Google Maps list feature I'm able to
access my favorite restaurants in the
area where they're staying I've actually
labeled the list using their new Emoji
feature to categorize Cuisines a bit
easier then boom right from the app I'm
able to share the list and get my
friends fed with some yummy yummy eats
if you're planning to travel perhaps in
New York City Google Maps has an awesome
new feature that can make your next
visit even more fun and easy immersive
you it will help you confidently decide
where where to explore using interactive
3D previews weather conditions traffic
and other info for example folks are
obsessed with visiting Washington Square
Park but it can be difficult to find if
you're in from out of town thanks to
immersive you you can get a 3D look at
what the park looks like and all the
different ways to get there so you can
know before you go click the link in
this description to download Google Maps
today and try these features out for
yourself thanks again to Google maps for
sponsoring this part of the video now
let's get back to your questions I saw a
video of a doctor on Tick Tock saying
that people who have a dark line in
their nail may have cancer is it true
this is true you could have cancer if
you have a dark line going through your
nail it's called a sub Uncle melanoma
but what I will say is there are other
causes of dark lines in your nails that
are not cancer so don't assume when you
have a dark line in your nails that it
is cancer instead use it as a as a
reason to go seek out medical advice and
check with your doctor if this is
something to be concerned with should I
eat protein before after my workout I
think the general consensus is to eat
after your workout and I know we talk
about that protein window quite often
and when I say protein window it's like
eating and getting protein and maybe
even some sugar immediately past a
workout in order to get maximal benefit
from like insulin release and getting
the nutrients into cells there's some
truth to that but there's also some
non-truth to that and the non-truth is
that while it is ideal to eat after your
workout within that window that impact
of eating in the window that benefit
usually goes away after you've been
training for a long period of time what
happens if you resuscitate someone who
has a DNR will you get fired I mean if
this is a genuine accident maybe not I
mean it'll be situationally dependent
there is a world where a family member
could sue you or even the patient could
sue you are there different kinds of
heimlich Maneuvers you're supposed to do
depending on the person like for a baby
versus average adult versus heavy person
yeah absolutely especially for babies
versus adults you got to think about a
baby's ability to regurgitate an object
and the way that you're gonna position
them is gonna be much different than an
adult and with a baby you want to start
with back Taps before you start doing a
proper heimlich maneuver and if you full
on press on a baby like this you could
really hurt the baby so it's it's a
different mechanism but here here are
the ones demonstrated for babies versus
adults why do they call that part of
your arm the funny bone and why does it
hurt in the weird way when it gets hit
the rest of my arm doesn't feel that way
when I bang it on something so why that
spot okay the funny bone is not a bone
there's a nerve that runs all the way
from your neck all the way to your pinky
called the ulnar nerve and it runs
inside this groove here called the ulnar
Groove now this nerve is really
protected it's protected well by muscle
by other tissue by fat all the way
except in this little Canal I think this
is like one of the the longest portions
of nerve that is unprotected in your
body when you hit that area you can
actually feel the Sensation that tingles
the weirdness that's nerve pain nerve
pain is very unique from other types of
aches so that that's why it feels funny
but also it's near the humerus so I
guess you could say it's also funny is
it bad to sleep with a fan blowing
directly on you I actually think that
it's not ideal think about it this way
if you're blowing a fan that means it's
probably hot in the room when you're hot
you start to sweat and when you sweat
the purpose of that is so that the sweat
evaporates and cools the surface of the
skin now the fan speeds that whole
process up and as a result that area
gets extra cool and when it gets extra
cool your body redirects blood away from
that area therefore that area gets less
circulation so it's not unusual if you
have a fan or an air conditioner blowing
on one side of your neck to wake up with
a stiff neck in fact one of the first
questions I ask when a patient comes in
with an acute stiff neck is were you
driving with the window open on a cold
day or did you sleep near an air
conditioner or an open window the red
heavy YouTube this is silly but does sex
count as exercise it does count as
exercise anything that gets your heart
rate up is technically going to be
exercise and research points to most
people burning only about a hundred
calories during like an average
20-minute session those numbers are
roundabout so you're not burning a ton
of calories think about it like a
Snickers bar has like 350 calories or
something so you're not even burning a
third of a Snickers bar when you have
sex what about taking a hot bath when
running a fever I don't understand the
whole bad thing when having a fever some
people think getting into a cold bath
will help cool you down don't do that if
you get into a really cold tub in the
midst of a fever your body can go into
shock that could be problematic going
into a hot bath doesn't necessarily make
it better just allow your body to
thermoregulate as it needs to remember
when you get into a hot tub and you have
a fever okay maybe it helps your body
get warmer without needing to develop
chills when you come out of the tub
you're going to get really cold because
that's the natural state of things
you're not going to right away get into
like an Uber warm environment and
therefore you're going to confuse your
body and make it difficult so just stay
out of water as much as you can unless
you like you're really dirty and you
need to clean yourself then you can do a
quick shower normal temperature Sarah
Gloria why is it that when someone has
poor vision takes off their glasses it
becomes a little easier to see if they
squint you're actually creating a focus
and you're able to see easier when
you're focused you're concentrating that
light on the back of your retina why
does one of my ankles crack more than
the other I mean this happens quite
often patients come in and they have no
symptoms other than sometimes their
knees or joints Make some noise and in
most instances it's fine there's nothing
scary going on and yeah joints make
noise and this is okay sometimes it can
be problematic because it's telling me
that there's damage going on but that is
such a rare exception that for most of
my patients I just say oh yeah my knees
crack too and I bend down and they can
hear my knees crack as well and why
doesn't want to crack more than the
other maybe you have a little excess
Scar Tissue maybe one side is slightly
longer maybe anatomically your bones are
slightly different so do I have the
perfect answer no but unless it's coming
with symptoms or it's progressively
getting worse I wouldn't necessarily
jump with alarm Bells what if someone as
big as Andre the Giant needed CPR could
the average person perform it on him or
would extra measures need to be taken
how big is Andre the Giant
my suspicion is if you're a small person
performing CPR on a seven foot five 500
pound person you would not be able to
compress the chest cavity enough to make
the hard pump blood to the rest of the
body therefore extra measures would need
to be taken perhaps one of those robots
that I've seen that they're testing out
in the field that does CPR maybe one of
those robots can do it what no pee whoop
at the end of the intro yeah so I don't
pee whoop after every intro and that's
because some videos are more serious and
it feels weird to say pee whoop when I'm
talking about a very serious topic I'm
also curious what is the current stance
of pee whoop are you for it are you
against it are you confused by it leave
me a comment I'm curious you ask me
questions but so do people on the street
click here to check that out and as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]
thank you